today we honor and thank all of our
veterans and for some their job isn't
over yet
a news now reporter sally jeremiah spoke
to some veterans
in the medical field who say their
experiences keep them going
during these very difficult times we
didn't get a choice in this war
this war came to us with coven 19 uh
this is what we would probably describe
our third wave um
but now we've got a better handle on
what we're dealing with from the front
lines overseas to the front lines of the
pandemic
ben rocklev the director of critical
care at southern hills hospital says
as coven numbers increase he is using
past experiences
in the present so i was a combat medic
in the army
from 0206 with 101st airborne uh during
that
time being deployed overseas uh you can
kind of relate to the pandemic situation
it was something that was new
uh when you're young going over to a war
zone lots of unknowns
almost 14 15 years later
it still comes down to in the hospital
setting
very much patient focused they're our
number one priority
but relating that to the military it's
all about the person to your left the
person to your right
dominique martinello is the chief
medical officer also
at southern hills hospital he says the
military taught him to work as a team
and teamwork is part in battling covid
the hospital is like a cavalry unit you
take a bunch of people that are all from
different backgrounds that have
different jobs
and put them all together and they have
to accomplish one mission martinello
also says
gathering intelligence like he did back
in the military also helps in treating
those who get sick
we're actually pulling in all the
research that we can possibly get there
is a
tremendous amount of data that needs to
be brought in from multiple specialties
and all assimilated so that we can
develop treatment strategies for these
patients
the only way that we're ever going to
actually win this war
is that if each and every person is
capable of fighting does
sally caramillo 8 news now sally thank
you
because these veterans see so much
firsthand they do want to share the
message
to continue to do your part wearing a
mask and limiting group
gatherings